I have often felt
like a fish out of water,
at various points
throughout my career.
But I've definitely come
to the realisation that my diversity,
and the difference that I bring,
is a real strength.
My first tip is...
It can weigh heavily
on your shoulders
and it can be quite frightening,
I think, to take a risk
and to do something different
and to break new ground.
Sometimes people will question you
and question whether
you're making the right decisions.
And sometimes you'll
question yourself, but that's okay.
My family come from
East Africa and India,
and so they are the children
of Britain's colonial past.
When I said to some members
of my extended family
that I was going to
work for the Foreign Office
there was an immediate sense of,
"How could you do this?
"Do you not remember
what they did to our people?"
But I think you need to recognise
that if you break new ground
there will be people
who question you,
but if you believe it's the right
thing to do, you need to persevere.
So my next tip is...
So I know that when I'm in new,
uncomfortable situations
I get a strong sense of fear,
and my flight mechanism kicks in.
And for me, that starts
with butterflies in my tummy,
and it goes on to
trying to think through,
"How can I get out
of this situation?"
So when I joined GCHQ,
I definitely felt in those early days
that sense of fear and flight.
And I'm surrounded by
some incredibly intelligent people
and they're gonna
find me out pretty quickly.
I've learnt, over the years,
that actually that feeling
only stays with me for
a relatively short period of time,
and if I ride it out and if I accept
fear, that actually it will be fine,
and the rational side
will kick in soon enough.
...that's my next top tip.
Because it's only through asking
and really listening
to what people say
that you can build relationships
of trust and confidence.
And in my job, I often meet people
from international backgrounds,
and the one thing that I always do
is to look at
what's on the front page
of their local newspaper that day.
Because that gives me something
topical to talk to them about.
What you're trying to do
is to make people feel
that you're really interested in them
and what they have to say to you.
My final tip is...
I think it's really, really important
when you're breaking new ground
to find somebody who will
encourage you to be yourself,
and will advocate for you.
For me, I was lucky that I was able
to find a champion
fairly early on in my career,
and she's somebody that I will turn
to and ask for advice and guidance.
But also, don't forget
that you are a champion yourself.
I learnt something which was
"lift as you climb,"
so making sure that you're helping
somebody else to succeed.
Part of what drives me
is proving people wrong.
The people who said that I couldn't
possibly work for the Foreign Office,
because it wasn't for people
from my background.
So success for me
isn't about the glory of being
at the top of an organisation,
it's about having
the maximum impact that I can,
but also about being an inspiration.
So if I can change the conversations,
and encourage people to dare
to be different and to take a risk,
then I feel like
I will have succeeded.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)